Welcome to my office.
I thought before we'd start I should
give you some tips on how to do well in
the class.
Step one is take a look at
the course readiness survey.
It's the minimum CS and Math-101 that
I think you need to even get started.
Next, there are these videos.
The videos are about
building your intuition.
And like other courses in the series,
there are little quizzes
sprinkled throughout.
I'd advise you not to skip
the quizzes because I like
to stick new concepts there.
And beyond the videos,
there are readings.
Where the videos are about
building your intuition,
the readings are about spelling
out all the gory, formal details.
And you're going to need those details
in order to do the mini projects and
the exams.
Finally, there are the mini projects.
The mini projects are about writing real
code because you don't really understand
an algorithm or a data structure until
you've tried to implement it yourself.
Especially, if you're trying to
understand something about engineering
tradeoffs.
Okay, so that's it for kind of
logistics and philosophy of the class.
With that fluffy stuff out of the way,
let's talk HPC.